[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans filcho dans ce
numéro on s'intéresse aux petites et
moyennes entreprises qui font face à une
actualité mouvementée nouvelle banque
publique d'investissement projet de loi
de finances 2013 on va décortiquer tout
cela avec vous je vifbelle bonjour
bonjour vous êtes présidente dans les
Yvelines de la CGPME c'est la
Confédération Générale du patronat des
petites et moyennes entreprises alors le
gouvernement est en place depuis à peine
6 mois quelle est l'ambiance au sein des
chefs d'entreprises alors euh l'ambiance
n'est pas excellente vous vous en doutez
euh on travaille dans un contexte qui
est très difficile avec une deuxième
activité euh avec une activité qui chute
pour la deuxème fois en 3 ans des
banquiers qui sont toujours toujours
très frileux un chômage qui continue à
augmenter dans ce contexte qui peut pas
être très agréable on a beaucoup de
réformes qui sont en cours hein vous en
avez énoncé quelques-unes et ces
réformes vont coûter vraiment beaucoup
d'argent et il va falloir trouver cet
argent coûte que coûte la CG PME des
ivelines compte un peu plus de 600
membres est-ce que vous sentez une
inquiétude au sein des chefs
d'entreprise déjà de vos membres et puis
est-ce que vous avez des demandes
d'adhésion qui qui alors oui j'ai
beaucoup deand qui m'envoie des mails
chose qu' qu' ne faisait pas avant il
nous nous contactai quand ils avaient
besoin de quelque chose là j'ai des
mails d'entreprises qui ont besoin de
parler besoin de me raconter besoin de
d'être soutenu et c'est c'est vraiment
la première fois qu'on voit ça de tous
les secteurs de tous les secteurs de
tous les secteurs et d'adhérents et de
pas adhérents alors vous avez fait
récemment parler de vous he la CGPME
nationale avec cette action contre le
projet de loi de la hausse de la
fiscalité des sessions immobilières
prévu dans le projet de loi de finance
2013 aujourd'hui à 19 % et la taxation
aurait atteint 60 %. comment s'est passé
cette négociation alors on a décidé de
négocier parce que il y a toute une
partie qui est favorable à nos PME et si
on rentre directement en disant on veut
pas c on veut pas ça on va perdre aussi
le positif qu'il y avait pour nos PME
donc ça il était pas question qu'on
l'accepte donc on a on a discuté en
particulier Jean-François roubau avec
Pierre Moscovici et avec flleur Pellerin
et ils ont entendu raison et ils nous
ont promis que en fait on revenait à un
taux de 19 %. oui parce que d'autres
mouvements patronaux aussi he ont bien
montré leur mécontentement face à cette
nouvelle mesure je pense notamment au
MDEF mais vous vous n'avez pas été
signataire hein de de ce texte alors on
n' pas été signataire je vous expliquer
pourquoi C il y avait une réunion qui
était en fait je vous en parle parce que
tout le monde en parle et que en disant
souvent des bêtises il y avait une
réunion qui était une réunion technique
c'est-à-dire que Jean-François roubau
n'yétait pas Pariso n'y était pas donc
c'était technique donc un communiqué a
été sorti par ce comité et quand on l'a
lu on a décidé de ne pas le signer parce
que il ne favorisait pas les PME PMI
c'était un communiqué qui favorisait de
façon assez cachée les grandes
entreprises mais ça vous étonne pas hein
le syndicat des petites et moyennes
entreprises c'est jusqu'à présent la
CGPME donc nous on a décidé de ne pas
signer et en fait il y avait une
récupération d'un mouvement qui s'était
créé qui était le mouvement des pigeons
et ce communiqué aussi avait pour but de
récupérer ce mouvement des pigeons donc
nous on a décidé ou bien il y avait des
modifications de ce communiqué où on ne
le signe pas pour défendre no PME voilà
c'est très clair et malgré le fait que
vous n'ayez pas signé ce texte vous avez
quand même pu avoir une action donc qui
a abouti de votre côté forcément puisque
nous on avait déjà mené notre action et
on a même eu peur avec ce communiqué
qu'on vient de ruiner tout ce qu'on
venait de faire quel est le dialogue
avec le gouvernement aujourd'hui alors
on a un dialogue mais ça donne
l'impression que chaque fois qu'on croit
qu'on va être un peu tranquille pof il y
a quelque chose qui retombe et on est
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps sur la défensive pour protéger nos
entreprises la situation économique est
compliquée he pour les chefs de PME pour
les aider à y voir plus clair la CGPME a
organisé une réunion pour recevoir ses
membres et connaître leurs difficultés
nous y étions on regarde ensemble ce
reportage
Patricia lrivière et Jean-Baptiste armé
sont chefs de deux jeunes PME dans un
contexte de crise et alors que de
nouvelles réformes sont en cours comment
tirer son épingle du jeu la CGPME des
Yvelines a donc organisé une réunion
pour éclairer ses membres sur les
dispositions gouvernementales à venir
c'est important qu'ils en échangent
effectivement parce qu'on on a des
choses à dire surtout vis-à-vis des des
événements qui se passent en ce moment
des des lois qui vont être décidées qui
vont être mises en place on a besoin de
réagir et de de de s'exprimer vis-à-vis
de ça bah la compétitivité nous on a
simplement une problématique de prix je
veux dire les prix tombent de plus en
plus la deuxième problématique c'est que
on est beaucoup on commence à être
attaqué beaucoup par les pays de l'Est
donc qui ont des coûts entre 4 et 6 fois
moins cher que nous et qui viennent sur
le marché français pour euh vendre de
l'impression grand format avec les
systèmes UPS avec ce genre de choses ils
arrivent avir des délais très court la
qualité quasiment la même euh sauf que
ils ont une main d'œuvre qui est quand
même beaucoup beaucoup moins cher que
nous on a tous les mêmes machine donc
forcément on veut tous faire tourner les
machines donc forcément le marché
diminue les prix se cassent un peu la
figure euh mais bon il suffit de se
battre quoi de trouver des nouveaux
marchés des nouvelles niches et on
arrive à s'en sortir outre la
compétitivité toujours ce problème
récurrent la relation avec les banques
qui conditionnent la trésorerie des
entreprises le contact avec les banques
est extrêmement difficile et le contact
avec les assureurs aussi sont
extrêmement difficiles moi j'entends des
gros grands discours et sur le terrain
je je je ne vois pas ce qui est dit euh
dans les grands discours euh notamment
vis-à-vis des banques vis-à-vis de des
administrations la simplification elle
est pas encore en place d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que mes clients sont un peu
débordé parmi les réformes en cours qui
font débat le projet de loi de finances
2013 il était notamment prévu une hausse
de la taxation des sessions immobilière
passant de 19 % aujourd'hui à près de 60
% après une très forte mobilisation de
la CGPME et des autres syndicats
patronaux la proposition du gouvernement
a finalement été
abandonnée
nous sommes toujours avec jeune
vievbelle présidente de la CGPME dans
les ivelines j'aimerais à présent
aborder avec vous une autre question la
question de l'entrepreneuriat au féminin
vous avez initié ce réseau maintenant
présent dans presque tous les
département de France c'était une
nécessité est-ce qu'il y a urgence
j'avais fait une étude suite à deux
constats le premier c'était un article
que j'avais lu de Viviane de beauaufort
qui est à les sec et qui avait donné des
chiffres àarm sur l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin donc à partir de là je suis
allée voir un petit peu ce qui se
passait dans les autres pays et je me
suis aperçu que les États-Unis qui
avaient un taux très bas aussi il y a
une vingtaine d'années maintenant ont
mis en place un tas de mesures pour les
femmes et on fait grimper ce taux
d'entrepreneuriat au féminin à 48 %.
donc là je me suis lancée dans une étude
j'ai écrit à tous les payux Européens
qui m'ont tous répondu ça a été vraiment
un élan extraordinaire pour voir un un
petit peu ce qui se passait dans tous
ces pays j'ai tiré des préconisations
pour faire progresser ce taux
d'entrepreneuriat alors pourquoi est-ce
que c'est important parce que vous avez
le papy boom baby boom et
donc on va avoir beaucoup d'entreprises
qui vont être à céd et si on n pas de
repreneurs supplémentair et on peut le
trouver dans ce creuseau de femmes qui
peuvent reprendre des entreprise on va
avoir des pertes encore de sur
l'entrepreneuriat on est en train de
mettre en place pour pour les différents
départements des outils qui vont
permettre de faire grimper ce taux
d'entrepreneuriat au féminin vous
parliez du problème de la reprise
d'entreprise he qu'il y aurait un manque
flagrant mais est-ce que c'est aussi
plus large concernant la parité dans les
conseils d'administration le niveau des
salaires aussi alors le niveau des
salaires et cetera va dépendre de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin ou pas
c'est un problème qui est plus général
là je suis en train de mettre au point
une attestation
d'égalité entre hommes et femmes pour
nos PME ça fon c'est-à-dire alors pour
l'instant je peux pas trop vousner de
détails on fera une émission là-dessus
dans pas longtemps mais ça sera
déclaratif hein je ne veux pas que on
ait encore des charges supplémentaires
pour nos entreprises et vous pensez que
ce sera efficace oui parce que je pense
que ce qu'il faut c'est euh familiariser
les chefs d'entreprise avec tous ces
problèmes mais je suis beaucoup plus
pour l'incitation la que la répression
vous disez il y a 3 ans le rapport que
vous aviez présenté au gouvernement a eu
un succès mais pas de suite est-ce que
avec ce nouveau gouvernement il y a un
écho plus important alors je sais pas si
c'est le fait que ça soit un nouveau
gouvernement ou si c'est que le les gens
muris que tout le monde a lu aussi un
petit peu plus ce qui est fait je
m'aperçois qu'il y a un nombre de
groupes qui reprennent mon
travail c'est très bien pour moi c'est
très bien plus je serai copié et plus je
me dirais qu'on a gagné est-ce qu'il y a
aussi des mentalités aussi à faire
évoluer et là il y a que le temps qui
peut aider si on ne fait pas changer les
mentalités depuis le plus jeune âge si
on fait pas bouger les stéréotypes et
cetera on navancera pas donc on est moi
ce que j'essaie de faire justement c'est
de faire avancer ce sujet à tous les
niveaux que ça soit au niveau de l'école
on a un groupe qui s'est mis dessus que
ça soit au niveau après les métiers dit
de femmes pour les hommes et des métiers
d'hommes pour les femmes je crois qu'il
faut que ça aille dans les deux sens si
on veut que ça progresse donc tout ça
c'est c'est tout à fait important et on
n arrivera plus si vous voulez à ce
qu'on à l'heure actuelle c'est une
autocensure des femmes c'estàd que quand
on propose un poste un peu plus élevé à
une femme elle est d'accord pour le
prendre si elle sait qu'elle va réussir
à 99 %. si par contre on propose de même
à un homme mais je suis pas du tout
misog gyne hein mais c'est des
statistiques qui sont données si on
propose à un homme à 50 % il se il dit
qu'il est capable de faire donc nous il
va falloir aussi qu'à 50 % on se dit je
suis capable et j'apprendrai bien merci
beaucoup je je vous en prie merci
partons à présent à la rencontre d'une
entreprise spécialisée en finance de
marché qui s'installe sur
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin et qui
est en plein
recrutement recruter ses salariés
localement c'est la démarche de cette
société de conseils et de services en
informatique créée à Montini au début
des années 90 et qui depuis a connu une
croissance fulgurante nos clients sont
très sensibles au fait que que les les
ingénieurs habitent pas très loin ne
soient pas très gênés par les les
transports le tissu local est aussi
assez intéressant il y a université donc
de versaill SaintQuentin il y a des
écoles qui s'implantent donc nous aussi
nous cherchons à faire vivre ce tissu
local parce que nous y croyons c'est une
société c'est une ville nouvelle donc
intéressante donc pensons que c'est
intéressant que tout le monde puisse y
travailler et y vivre passé de 250 à 700
salariés après le rachat l'été dernier
de la filiale française d'un groupe
américain la société a installé son
siège à Paris tout en conservant un
service Recherche et Développement de 25
personnes à guyant cours une antenne en
fort développement puisque 50 postes
sont ouverts au recrutement profil
recherchés des bac + 5 issus d'école
d'ingénieur ou de l'université une
première expérience est demandée mais
pas nécessaire SOFTEAM possède en effet
une université en interne l'avenir
semble radieux pour la PME devenue
grande entreprise qui table à présent
sur un développement international nous
avons des projets effectivement de
d'internationalisation plutôt du côté
Asie pour accompagner nos grands clients
certains de nos grands clients dans le
domaine de la finance sont évidemment
sur Paris mais aussi on pense à Londres
on pense aussi à Hong Kong Singapour
notamment il nous demande de les
accompagner softteam compte plusieurs
centaines de clients au profil divers de
la banque au grand groupe industriel en
passant par les assurances elle recrute
chaque année en moyenne 150 à 200
[Musique]
personnes avant de se quitter quelques
dates à noter dans vos agendas on
parlait de l'entrepreneuriat au féminin
avec notre invité et bien la cité des
métiers à traap propose un atelier sur
le droit des femmes au travail c'est le
vendredi 16 novembre à 10h la CGPME
propose un déjeuner ouvert à tous sur
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin c'est le 6
décembre à
mantelajolie et à l'occasion du Mois de
l'économie sociale et solidaire le
Ministre Benoît amont interviendra lors
d'une conférence intitulée les
coopératives une force à part jeudi 22
novembre à 20h30 à l'auditorium de Trapp
c'est terminé pour ce filcho je vous
retrouve pour un nouveau numéro le vend
V 23 novembre consacré au constructeur
automobile Fiat installé à
[Musique]
trappe